I mean do you think for for you a lot of
the people maybe that you know that
we're in film school or people that have
talked to you after screenings are
making films because they're not always
shooting I know you've said that in the
past always be shooting and I don't know
if that meant just on set always have
and I'll be ready to roll or just even
during these down times they weren't
making something they weren't doing
something in terms no I think that goes
to what you were saying earlier about
the that that people get scared easily
if the feedback isn't positive
immediately so everyone's always waiting
for someone to give them to allow them
to believe in an idea to give them a
green light and go let go but no one
will you know so if you don't just go
and I think that's what I meant by
always be shooting don't wait for
someone else to give you the green light
or the money or the support because it
99 percent won't be there and the people
that are not shooting other people that
have been developing the same script for
ten years and they're waiting for
financing for 20 mil for someone to give
them 20 million dollars that's not going
to happen you know I think the people
that are shooting other people that grab
the video camera and said I'm going to
do this quirky little thing now and see
how it turns out and then they show to
someone who sees something in it and
then you go from there but you need to
be doing it rather than waiting and
hoping that someone will allow you to do
it and we have all the tools today right
there's no excuse anymore to to wait
because we just don't need the same
resources that we needed 20 years ago
everyone can shoot a movie on their
iPhone like tangerine or movie
what about short films do you feel like
after maybe one or two as you talked
about being in film school and it's it
was a safe place to kind of fail but
then people that get caught in this
perpetual short addiction is that good
no no I think that is a problem because
it's just about how people look at stuff
if you haven't that might have been the
case years ago that someone would
look at a short film and go like this is
brilliant will now make the feature
version of it but you can count and
those example exceeds examples exist but
you can count that on one hand I think
what you have to do today is you have to
make a feature as time-consuming and as
you know grueling as that is you have to
get that feature into a festival and you
have to get people to see it and if
possible win an award and that's the
moment that people will start paying
attention and we'll give you your next
project because they you have to try to
put yourself into their mindset they
have to justify why they hired you to
their bosses right so if you've made a
short film and you next want to do a
feature you need someone who is brave
and courageous enough to close that gap
for you and say I can justify to my boss
that on the basis of this short film I
gave you millions to do this feature and
I don't think there are enough brave
people out there whereas if you have
made a feature that has won an award
it's much easier for this guy to go like
well she has already made a feature that
won an award so I didn't take any risk
offering her this new movie so this
person if that movie doesn't do well
doesn't get fired you know I think it's
all I think we talked about that too
less then it's all fear-based
people don't want to be seen taking
risks because if that goes badly they
lose their job so I think you have to
give them as much of a reason to trust
you with something that they can defend
when talking to their bosses as possible
and that means make a feature I would
after film school urge everyone to not
waste plan making short films
you